Hôm khung hàng truy trí tại pháp tiếp tục lâu thang sau khi tủ tổn nước này
ông Siba Stian le có ngu, nộp lơn tư trước ngày 6 tháng 4, chỉ vây giờ sau khi công bố nội cá mới
Lòng thái này khiến chính quyền của tổn thủ ema Nguay Mặt Rông, dời vào thế bế tắt nghiêm trọng
Nên dấu lần thứ 5-3, 5-3 bị trí tủ tổn kẻ đến năm 2020, theo đều LZ, ông Mặt Rông đã chấp thật đơn tổ chức
và hiện đối mặt với 3 xe lợi trọn khó khăn, một là bụng nhận tủ tổn mới, 2 là dải tán của hội để tổ chức bầu cửa sớm
khoảng 3 tự dời nhẹm sợ, phương án ông Mặt Rông kiến quét bắt bỏ, tuyên việc tiêm kiếm người kế nhé ông Lekoc nư không hề dễ dàng
khi các đảng phái trong khu hội vẫn chia dễ sâu sắc, dựa bà khu chính, lên mình chung hiểu của Mặt Rông,
cạnh ta và đảng khu khí ước tập hệ cu ra, aero e nở, tinh hình chở nên tội tệ hơn sau thất bà của các nộ lực thông của ông Ngan Xe Cuczah
Hãy đời thủ tổn chứ ông Lekoc nư, lậu Mi Chen Vanier và Francois Beiru,
đều mất chức về chân cả quang chính xác cắt giảm chí tiêu, nhằm sự li mức thông của Ngo sách lợ nhất của Bộ Đồng Arov
ngoài ra của Cuczah, cụng quét nhận tổn thống mắt quân trong cộng bầu cử, nắm hàng hình không trong hàng hiệm bây,
đảng làm giá tăng chia dễ, khi các đảng phái tập trung cùng của VH, thầy B hợp tác là pháp,
rồi quả sách nhận định trong bối càng bề tắc giao dài, tổn thông ema Ngo ngọt thêm bột phải tình đến phương án dài tạm của hội,
bọn thành lập chính phủ đến mấy, điều vụn thêm thời trong nền chính trị pháp hiện đại.